Up until the 19th century, England only had
two universities, that of Cambridge and Oxford.
This meant that for much of English history
the educated elites, who were at the center
of political, social, and economic affairs
of the country, were often educated at either
Cambridge or Oxford. Even when new universities
started to be established, like the University
of Durham or the University of London, Oxford
and Cambridge still retained their ‘exclusive’
‘elite’ status. As historian Caroline
Elkins put it, ‘Oxford and Cambridge were
natural codas for British ruling-class education’.
These two universities even had, up until
1950, their own two MPs (each) in the British
Parliament; and so, with their status as the
educational institutions for the ‘elites’,
and their direct connection to Parliament,
it should not be surprising that Oxford and
Cambridge were directly connected to, and
benefited from, the establishment and running
of the British Empire.
Some Scottish Universities, however, and exclusive
Public Schools (and later English Universities
like London and Durham), also had their own
connections to the British Empire, it wasn't
just the universities of Oxford and Cambridge.
With that said, the University of Oxford’s
imperial connections are often touted as the
most expansive. Being the oldest University
in the English speaking world, and being more
focused on humanities than Cambridge was,
Oxford usually attracted the most politically
active students. Therefore, as Brockliss states
… ‘Much can and should be made of Oxford
alumni’s domination of the top posts in
the government and the civil service, and
the role this played in securing the University's
position.’ A position, which made ‘Oxford's
connection with the [British] Empire as old
as the Empire itself’.
But, how did this University of Oxford’s
connection with the Empire actually look like,
and what are the Imperial legacies of the
University today? Well, let's find out …
The history of the British Empire usually
begins with the 16th century Tudor conquest
of Ireland which also coincided with the English
expeditions into the Americas. To what extent
the University of Oxford was actually needed
in these early days of the Empire is hard
to say. Many ruling class elites would have
participated in English imperial enterprises
whether they went to Oxford or not. But, it
was at the University of Oxford where many
ruling class elites acquired an academic education
which often proved useful for, among other
things, conducting said imperial enterprises.
The English crown quickly recognized this
usefulness of having academically educated
men in the state service and so, in the 16th
century, it increasingly turned to the University
when it wanted a supply of academically educated
men. For example, Elizabeth the first, during
her visit to Oxford in 1566, requested that
the heads of the University help her recruit
more Oxford educated men into her service.
This action resulted in Oxford educated men
like Thomas Bodley, Walter Raleigh, and Humphrey
Gilbert playing vital roles in Elizabeth's
government. Bodley was an important diplomat
while Raleigh and Gilbert partook in the Elizabethan
conquest of Ireland and both subsequently
gained plantations in Ireland from that conquest.
Raleigh and Gilbert also conducted several
expeditions into the Americas. All of these
Imperial enterprises, on part of Raleigh and
Gilbert, required a degree of violence, after
all, as historian Delahaye states, colonization
always ‘carried with it a degree of violence’.
But, it was in Ireland that this violence
turned particularly brutal. Humphrey Gilbert,
who was called ‘England’s first Empire
Builder’ and ‘Elizabeth’s Racketeer’,
partook in a systematic war of terror in southern
Ireland killing all the Irish that dared stand
against him. In his own words, if the Irish
do not surrender ‘[I will] win it by force,
how many lives so ever it cost, putting man,
woman, and child of them to the sword … Being
for my part constantly of this opinion that
no conquered nation will ever yield willingly
their obedience for love but rather for fear’.
Another notable University of Oxford graduate
from this time was Thomas Harriot. He worked
closely with Sir Walter Raleigh and, when
Raleigh captured and brought back to England
a couple of Carolina Algonquin Indians, Harriot
thoroughly questioned them on the New World
and learned their language; becoming the first
man in England to learn a native American
Language. Harriot also had extensive navigational,
mathematical, and cartographic skills; all
of which made him an instrumental figure in
the establishment of the eventually unsuccessful
Roanoke Colony. Harriot's navigational guides
and maps were used by yet another notable
Oxford alumnus, Thomas Roe, who, using Harriot's
maps, went into the Amazon in search of the
mythical El dorado. With that said, Thomas
Roe is actually more well remembered for being
the first official royal English ambassador
sent to the Mughal Empire in 1615. This was
done at the behest of the British East India
Company. But, more on the East India Company
later.
As the English state continued to pursue ever
more imperial enterprises all around the world,
it needed an ever increasing number of educated
men who could act as diplomats like Roe, as
explorers like Raleigh, as cartographers and
polyglots like Harriot, and as imperialists
like Gilbert. Therefore, as long as the crown
continued to pursue imperial enterprises,
it also continued to acknowledge and support
the University of Oxford’s role as a necessary
provider of educated men for those enterprises.
This support by the crown can be seen, for
example, when James the fourth of Scotland
and first of England came to power. He was,
at least on paper, the first ruler of the
entire British Isles, and, as such, he wanted
to strengthen the bond between all the places
and peoples he ruled over by creating a quote
‘union of hearts and minds’. One of the
ways James tried to foster this union of hearts
and minds was by promoting and financing the
education of protestant students at Oxford
that came from all over the British isles,
from Ireland to Scotland, and even Jersey.
By doing this, James hoped to foster unity
among all these people, of mostly aristocratic
blood, who would then either go back home
or partake in imperial expeditions abroad,
depending on where they went, helping the
crown either retain or expand imperial control.
It was also at this point that the University
started to play another important role for
the empire. A more scholarly one. The gradual
development of the British Empire brought
with it also the development of a British
Imperial ideology; and it was the academic
environment at the University of Oxford which
proved particularly favorable for debating,
expanding, and eventually promulgating this
developing imperial ideology.
For example, during James’ support of the
university in order to foster a ‘union of
hearts and minds’, Samuel Purchas, who was
educated at the other place but also became
a fellow at Oxford, wrote about how the British
Empire is an empire of not just English, but
also of Protestant Irish, Scottish, and Welsh
peoples. Purchas basically used the academic
setting of the university to teach and publish
writings that supported the narrative and
ideology that James was trying to foster.
Purchas also supported the Empire, writing
that all protestant British people ought to
go colonize the new world together for Britain.
He was echoed in this by another Oxford professor,
and geographer, Richard Hakluyt, who also
wrote and taught in support of colonization
in North America. However, unlike Samuel Purchas,
Hakluyt emphasized more the idea of just ‘English
exceptionalism’ and the English Christenizing
and civilizing duty against native ‘savagery’.
This way the University of Oxford’s connection
to the empire became not only through its
graduates but also through some of its academic
output. With that said, the University was
still an independent institution, and, even
though often heavily affected by the state’s
agenda and contemporary society, it did not
always have scholars that would present a
coherent ‘empire is good’ argument, nor
did all the students and professors at the
university suddenly start to solely be interested
in imperial topics. Most Oxford fellows and
graduates were still mostly concerned with
the clerical profession. It wouldn’t really
be until the 19th century that Oxford's connection
with the Empire became fully internalized
throughout the university.
Nevertheless, this valuable role the University
of Oxford played, both educating the ruling
elite and providing an academic setting for
imperial thought to develop, was recognized
and supported by every subsequent British
ruler after James. Even during the brief time
of the Protectorate, Cromwell, just like the
monarchs before him, reaffirmed the university's
important role for the Empire and sought graduates
from the University (and Cambridge) for his
state’s service.
It should, therefore, not be surprising that
when it came to the ever increasing colonial
British efforts in the Americas, Oxford men
were represented in high numbers. Walter Raleigh
founded Virginia, William Penn founded Pennsylvania,
and James Oglethorpe founded Georgia, all
Oxford alumni. In fact 5 out of the first
9 Governors (initially just called presidents
of the company) of the Virginia Company Colony
were Oxford graduates. Another Oxford graduate,
John Lock, who was called ‘the Father of
Liberalism’, was also the secretary to the
Council of Trade and Plantations of the Carolinas,
and he helped draft the Constitution of the
Carolinas; which gave the Carolina planters
absolute power over their enslaved chattel
property. John Lock was also instrumental
in setting up the legal groundworks for ‘the
expropriation of aboriginal lands in America’
which was used by the British, and later the
American, government for centuries.
Speaking of the Carolinas, it was a colony
in which another notable Oxford graduate,
and later also the University’s Chancellor,
had a large financial stake in, Edward Hyde
the first Earl of Clarendon. In fact, what
became South Carolina was known for a while
as Clarendon province. Clarendon was also
involved in the conquest of Ireland, and was
later in his life accused of using his political
influence to procure and sell charters for
the settlement of Ireland, making him a lot
of money. He also once stated that 'No man
… is more solicitous to establish Ireland
upon a true protestant English interest than
I am’. Clarendon was also a prolific writer
and at the end of his life he donated the
royalties from his books to the University
of Oxford, which used the profits to build
the Clarendon building, which you’re looking
at right now, with his statue right there.
The amount of money the university made from
donations from people like Clarendon is hard
to determine. All the way up until 1870 the
University didn’t really keep consistent
accounting books and some donations, like
in the case of Clarendon, weren't always direct
cash, making it even more complicated to track.
Not to mention that some accounting documents
got simply lost or destroyed over time. However,
it is unquestionable that some of the donations
the university received throughout the centuries
came from imperialists, from slave owners,
slave traders, and others.
With that said, the inconsistent accounting
books that do remain show that the University's
wealth actually came largely from investments
and holdings it had accrued over the course
of its long existence, not from donations.
Large majority of these holdings and investments
where in England but the university also invested
in some of the colonial companies of the time
like the South Sea Company or the Royal African
Company, both of which primarily traded in
African slaves. This should perhaps not be
surprising as, for example, 4 of the 24 founding
officers of the Royal African Company were
Oxford alumni.
The most well known Oxford alumnus imperialist
who made his fortune from slavery is Christopher
Codrington, one of the largest 17th century
slave owners of the Brititsh West Indies.
When Codrington died in 1710 he donated a
large sum of his money and books to the University
of Oxford All Souls college which promptly
used that money to build this library with
a Roman style statue of him in the middle.
The library has been known ever since as the
Codrington Library. Well, at least up until
2020, when the Condrington name was finally
dropped due to the fact that the money he
donated to the University was made from Slave
labor. The Roman style statue of him, however,
still remains inside the library.
Another way the University gained money was
by patrons funding professorships or scholarships.
Sometimes these were funded by the parliament,
sometimes by the monarchy, sometimes by rich
individuals, and sometimes by companies. For
example, the East India Company funded several
scholarships in the 17th century. Securing
these funds wasn’t very hard for the university
considering its expansive alumni network.
The last way the University financially benefited
from the British Empire that I will talk about
is by the acquisition of knowledge and artifacts.
Some artifacts and books the University acquired
were purchased legally by the university,
or imperial traders which then donated it
to the university. Others, however, were purchased
illegally, or stolen, or acquired through
imperial conquest or coercion. Sometimes the
university wasn’t even involved and it was
the professors of the university that made
these deals on their own. And, sometimes,
like in the case of the 17th century Selden
Map of China or the 16th century Codex Bodley,
we don’t really know how they got acquired.
However, as the British Empire spread across
the world, it is undeniable that the University
benefited from the knowledge and artifacts
brought back to Britain. Some of the University
professors even had agreements with colonial
companies, like the Levant Company or the
East Indian Company, to bring them back all
the books they acquired on their expeditions.
In the 18th century, Oxford professors and
alumni continued to play vital roles all around
the British Empire. For example, William Jones
and Robert Chambers were Oxford professors
who were sent, in the latter half of the 18th
century, to Bengal, to act as local judges
for the East India Company. While there, William
Jones became the first British scholar of
Sanskrit and Robert Chambers was one of the
judges that presided over the notorious Maharaja
Nandakumar case.
To explain, Maharaja Nandakumar was said to
have been the first Indian sentenced to be
hanged by the British after an official British
court case in 1775. Meaning it signaled the
ever growing control the British government
had over parts of India. The court case itself
was a sham. Nandakumar, an Indian tax collector
hired by the East India Company, accused the
first British Governor General of Bengal,
Warren Hastings, of corruption. He even provided
several documents to prove this. Hasting quickly
denied this and accused Nandakumar of forgery
of the said documents. Rather than Hastings
being tried, it was Nandakumar who was sent
to court for forgery. Knowing the British
court would rule in favor of the Governor,
Nandakumar asked to be judged by a jury of
his peers as allowed under the English common
law. The court obliged but then went and filled
the jury with only British people who didn’t
even know the local language and had to have
an interpreter during the entire trial. Naturally
this phony trial ruled in favor of Hastings
and sentenced Nandakumar to death. This trial
set the precedent for what the Indians could
expect if they dared raise legal issues against
British officials. A contemporary British
MP, Edmund Burke, stated ‘The accuser, they
saw hanged. [While] the culprit, without acquittal
or enquiry, triumphs on the ground of that
murder: a murder not of Nandakumar only. But
of all living testimony, and even of evidence
yet unborn. From that time not a complaint
has been heard from the natives against their
governor.’
It wasn’t just in India, however, where
Oxford judges took part in prominent imperial
court cases. Back home, in England, the practice
of Slavery by the British Empire had started
to be hotly debated by the end of the 18th
century. The University of Oxford’s relationship
with slavery was a complicated one. On the
one hand, the University definitely benefited
from the money being generated by slave labor,
whether through investments, donations, or
payments from students that came from slave
owning families. But, on the other hand, the
university also had prominent abolitionist
students, professors, and even awarded an
honorary degree to James Beattie for his work
against slavery. Probably the most notable
Oxford abolitionist, well, sort of, was William
Murray, the 1st Earl of Mansfield. He was
the judge in the 1772 Somersett’s Case which,
for the first time in English history, stated
that there was no precedent for slavery in
English common law. This did not outlaw slavery
in the Empire as a whole but it did make slaves
residing in England technically free of their
master’s control. Mansfield, in the Somersett’s
Case, upheld the interpretation of English
common law championed by another contemporary
Oxford legal Professor, William Blackstone,
who stated that slavery was ‘repugnant to
natural law and reason’ and that ‘pure
and proper slavery does not, nay cannot, subsist
in England’.
With that said, abolishing slavery in the
whole Empire was a slow porcess and it took
well over another half a century for it to
truly be abolished. This was partly because
slave owners like Charles Ellis, an Oxford
graduate, had large amounts of wealth which
they used extensively for lobbying in defense
of slavery. One of the lobbying tactics used
by the planters centered around the ever increasing
18th century recialization of the world. In
essence, many British planters started to
argue their right for owning slaves came from
their racial superiority. This idea of racial
superiority came from an 18th century development
of a British Imperial ideology of Anglo-Saxon,
or Teutonic, or just British exceptionalism.
The ideology of British or English exceptionalism
wasn’t, however, only based on race. It
also included a belief in superior English
culture, religion, civic development, intellect,
science, etc. This idea of English exceptionalism
can be traced to the earliest days of the
British Empire, but it was in the 18th century
that it truly solidified in the British society.
Oxford's scholars weren’t as active in the
creation of this Imperial ideology as for
example Scottish Universities’ graduates
were, but, some, like William Pitt the elder
and Edward Gibbon, both of whom went to Oxford
but did not finish their studies, did play
their part.
William Pitt was championed by his contemporaries
to be ‘a Minister, to whose efforts the
British Empire owes its safety and its fame’,
for he ‘armed the hardy race of the north’
because ‘the north has ever been propitious
to conquest’. Gibbon reaffirmed such statements
of a hardy race of the north in his historical
writings where he once wrote that ‘we [the
English] may assume a conspicuous place among
all the inhabitants of the earth’.
This ‘conspicuous’ place of the English
in the world, this propitiousness of theirs
to conquest, this exceptionalism of theirs,
was then used in the 19th and early 20th century
to justify the British Empire. In other words,
because the Anglo-Saxons, the English, were
perceived by themselves as so exceptional
and superior, and because Britain was seen
as being so ‘Great’, it ought to colonize
as much of the world as possible for the quote
‘common good’. It was the English burden,
which later became known as the ‘white man’s
burden’, to spread their perceived superior
culture, religion, language, and race around
the world to, theoretically, eventually raise
all the other peoples of the world to their
level.
It was this 19th century Imperial ideology
of a ‘white man’s burden’, which developed
from the ideology of English exceptionalism,
that the University of Oxford played a central
role in devising and promulgating. John Ruskin,
an Oxford arts professor, lectured on how
England ‘must found colonies as fast and
as far as she is able, formed of her most
energetic and worthiest men;—seizing every
piece of fruitful waste ground she can set
her foot on’. James Froude, an Oxford history
professor, stated that ‘when the inequality
[between the colonizers and the natives] has
been proved beyond dispute by long and painful
experience - the wisdom, and ultimately the
duty, of the weaker party is to accept the
benefits which are offered in exchange for
submission.’ Froude also echoed the speech
of Thomas Macaulay who stated, ‘It may be
that … by good government we may educate
our subjects into a capacity for better government,
that, having become instructed in European
knowledge they may in some future age demand
European institutions … The scepter may
pass away from us but … there is an Empire
exempt’. Basically, the civilizing mission,
which is the ‘white man’s burden’, was
seen as exempting the British Empire from
the conquest, violence, and exploitation of
the natives. In this context, the British
patted themselves on the back when they finally
abolished slavery in 1834, which was seen
as part of their civilizing mission of uplifting
the poorer races from slavery. The idea of
racial superiority still remained, but it
was no longer used to justify slavery, it
was now used to justify the world’s racial
hierachy with the English and their civlizing
Empire being at the top.
Robert Southey, William Stubbs, Alfred Milner,
Charles Lucas, Albert Dicey, Edward Freeman,
Reginald Coupland and many many more were
all Oxford men championing the idea of the
white man’s burden. As historian Brockliss
states ‘Most influential dons (Oxford professors)
were ardent Imperialists.’
Now Britain was not unique in justifying its
Empire with the argument of a ‘civilizing
mission’. Almost every 19th century Empire
did so. But such whataboutist arguments don't
really excuse the actions. Up until now I
have talked about the British Empire as it
pertains to the University of Oxford, and
I shall continue doing that. But, I will recommend
that you read this book Legacy of Violence
:A
History of the British Empire This book is
great if you want to learn just how much violence
was integral to the British Empire. And, it
was written by a Harvard Professor.
With that said, there were also some Oxford
men who tried to fight against the persistent
racism and imperial violence of the time.
William Tozer, an Oxford graduate, was appointed
as the head of the Universities’ Christian
Mission to Africa. He focused on converting
the locals and curtailing the Islamic Slave
trade. Unlike most British people in Africa,
Tozer never used violence and he always tried
to work with the local African institutions
rather than against them. Also, while in Africa,
Tozer noticed that many of the English where
blatantly racist towards the Africans, he
stated that the ‘Englishmen generally have
a very much less kindly feeling towards a
free negro (black) than the Arabs have towards
their slaves.’ Many Englishmen talk of freeing
the Africans from Arab slavery only to then
treat them worse than the Arab slavers. This
statement was, of course, a hyperbole to prove
a point but it was based in truth.
Coming back to the University of Oxford. The
role of the university as a place of education
for the empire’s elite and as a place for
the creation and promotion of imperial ideology,
truly reached its zenith in the 19th and early
20th century. As Brockliss states when talking
about the 19th century ‘It was considered
to be Oxford’s primary function to take
callow youths and turn them into intelligent,
upright, and dedicated servants of a British
civilizing mission’. Basically, Oxford men
were expected and taught to take up the ‘white
man’s burden’.
Even Rudyard Kipling, the person who popularized
the term the ‘white man’s burden’ with
his infamous ‘white man’s burden poem’
was nominated for the nobel prize in literature
by an Oxford professor, Charles Oman. Oman
himself wrote a book on English history where
in the last sentence of the 740 page book
he concluded with, ‘the future of the world
lies in the hands of the Anglo-Saxon race’.
The influence the university of Oxford graduates
had over the British Empire in the 19th and
early 20th century was truly astounding. As
historian Caroline Elkins put it, ‘Given
the sheer size of Britain’s far-flung empire,
it was impossible to micromanage day-to-day
rule in these areas. Instead, the prevailing
ethos was to “trust the man on the spot,”
which officials in London did with great regularity.
In practice, this meant a very small cadre
of recruits joined the empire’s civil service,
coming from mostly schools such as Oxford
and Cambridge’.
Just how many Imperial recruits actually came
from Oxford? Well, ‘Over the whole period
of British rule in India, 15 Governor-Generals
or Viceroys came from Oxford’. Also, between
1895 and 1914 around 50% of all successful
applicants for either home or colonial civil
service came from Oxford. This also created
a positive feedback loop through the old boys
network. That is, the more Oxford men were
employed in the British Imperial Service the
more Oxford men were hired. As Richard Symonds
points out, ‘the examinations for entrance
to the top grade of the home and Indian civil
service were designed to advantage Oxford
graduates’ mainly because they were designed
by Oxford graduates. Toynbee Junior, an Oxford
fellow, even stated that if a student came
to Oxford not knowing what he wanted to do
in life, he would simply be signed up for
the Indian Civil Service, because quote ‘An
Indian civil service career was assured to
any … [Oxford] man who could not do better
than that.’
The benefits the University of Oxford saw
from all its graduates becoming integral parts
of the Imperial state were tremendous. Not
only did most of its students have a guaranteed
job, if they wished to take it, but Oxford
became the imperial school, sometimes even
at the cost of colonial schools. For example,
George Curzon, an Oxford graduate and the
viceroy of India, who also later became the
University of Oxford’s chancellor, closed
down India’s School of Forestry at Cooper’s
Hill and relocated it, along with its staff,
to the University of Oxford. Oxford's forestry
school, right behind me, was still funded
by the Indian Colonial government but it was
now in Oxford, for the benefit of Oxford students.
Other subjects taught in Oxford, and other
British universities of the time, which could
not be studied in India included Anthropology,
Mineralogy, and Geology. The University of
Oxford also built The Indian Institute which
was to help educate the future public servants
of India (all in Oxford).
Of course, if Indians wished to study all
these subjects they theoretically could have
applied to Oxford but their chances of getting
in were much smaller than for any British
student. One University fellow, Herbert Blakiston
(Trinity), even stated in 1913, ‘I should
say that we … are not anxious to encourage
Indian students to come to Oxford’. The
fact that Curzon later became the chancellor
of the University also didn’t help the Indians
studying at Oxford. Curzon held quite racist
beliefs against the Indians ever since his
viceroyalty when he stated that all Indians
are ‘less than schoolchildren’, and while
being the chancellor of the university he
was said to have been constantly paranoid
about the loyalty of the Indian students.
Some Indian students were even afraid of submitting
papers in modern history classes because they
thought the essays would be sent to the colonial
office in order to judge their loyalties to
the Empire.
This kind of prejudice and racism wasn’t,
of course, only against Indian students. All
potential Oxford students deemed as ‘non-white’
had to fight against quite racist sentiment
if they wished to study at Oxford. And, keep
in mind, by design, Oxford, along with other
English universities of the time, was the
only place in the empire where you could study
certain subjects. Therefore, of course, the
most qualified people for higher office jobs
ended up being, for the most part, British.
Another way the University benefited from
the Empire was through the university press.
As the Empire expanded so did the reach of
the Oxford University press. From here, at
Walton Street, the Oxford University Press
managed branches all across the empire. Easily
securing distribution and print licenses thanks
to the university’s alumni network. This
way the University Printing Press indirectly
hindered the development of local knowledge
distribution in favor of Oxford's knowledge
distribution. This knowledge was Anglocentric
and sometimes quite racist. For example, in
1911, the University press started printing
this book for primary schools. It’s called
A History of England written by an Oxford
history professor C. R. L. Fletcher. In it,
Fletcher describes Ireland as a ‘spoilt
child’ who is ‘poor, disloyal, and ignorant’,
he goes on to say that the descendence of
African slaves in the carribean are ‘lazy,
vicious and incapable of any serious improvement
… and quite useless’, black South Africans
are described as ‘fierce savages’, and
the aboriginals of Australia are ‘nothing
but a few miserable blacks’. Fletcher then
concludes with ‘the natives everywhere welcome
the mercy and justice of our rule.’ … This
book was being actively printed by the University’s
press until 1954. Guyana, after it gained
independence from the British, even banned
the book because it was deemed too racist.
When it came to the British colonies in Southern
Africa, here too, Oxford fellows were represented
in large numbers. For example, an Oxford graduate,
Alfred Milner, became the governor of the
Cape Colony, and later the High Commissioner
for Southern Africa. During his time in Africa,
Milner’s entire staff was almost exclusively
made up of Oxford graduates, which outsiders
called Milner’s Oxford ‘kindergarten’.
Milner worked closely with Cecil Rhodes, another
Oxford graduate, and several other Imperialists,
to develop the foundation for a quote ‘wholesale
exploitation of black labor in the white owned
mines, and the rise of the apartheid regime
that, decades later, would come to power on
the racist coattails of Milner’s Oxford
ceoterie’. Milner also send a letter to
his Oxford friend Asquith upon his arrival
to South Africa in which he stated that ‘You
have only to sacrifice the nigger (blacks)
absolutely … and then the game is easy’.
However, it was Milner’s friend, Cecil Rhodes,
who is seen as the most notorious South African
Imperialist. You have probably seen this picture
before, specially in the context of African
Colonialism, well that picture is the Rhodes
Colossus, that is Cecil Rhodes. Rhodes was
the quintessential British Imperialist, he
believed in the white man’s burden narrative,
he believed in the superiority of the Anglo-Saxon
race, he organized and conducted brutal for
profit conquests of today's Zambia and Zimbabwe,
and, as the Prime Minister of the Cape colony,
enacted segregationist laws which helped,
along with Milner’s laws, the beginnings
of the racist apartheid regime in South Africa.
Rhodes even stated that ‘you must govern
the natives … as a subject race’.
During an 1896 rebellion in today’s Zimbabwe
Rhodes, against the orders of the British
government, personally led an army to crush
the rebellion. He implemented brutal scorched
earth tactics ordering his officers to quote
‘do the most harm you can to the natives
around you … kill all you can’.
Rhodes financed his political and imperial
campaigns with the money of his business partners
like Alfred Beit, and with his own money which
he primarily made from South African and later
Rhodesian Mines. These mines were run on the
‘compound system’ which often (but not
always) resembled slavery in all but name.
To quote Rob Turrell, ‘Compounds provided
the framework for the total control of African
workers. Once inside these military-style
barracks, workers lost all access to the outside
world for the length of a contract.’ While
in these compounds many workers were also
under the supervision of white ‘overseers’
called ‘masters’. An African technically
did not have to take up this contractual job
but Rhodes, as the Prime Minister of the Cape
Colony, implemented the Hut Tux, and more
importantly, the Glen Grey Act, which stated
that ‘Every male black person … who in
the magistrate's opinion was capable of labour,
had to pay a tax of ten shillings per year,
but would not have to pay the tax if he had
worked.’ This meant that Africans had to
take up jobs in order to not pay extra taxes
or even to have money to pay taxes, and almost
all jobs for blacks in South Africa were contractual
jobs.
When Rhodes died he gave a large sum of the
money he made from his mines and Imperial
activities to the University of Oxford. Part
of the money went to establish the Rhodes
Scholarship with the Rhodes House behind me
and part of it was given to Oriel College
Oxford which built this building with a statue
of Rhodes at the top.
Rhodes, however, wasn’t the only South African
Imperialists to donate money to the University.
Abe Bailey, for example, funded a library
and a reading room for Oxford students studying
Colonial Geography and History. Bailey, just
like Rhodes, made most of his money in mines
run on the aforementioned compound system.
In particular, Bailey made a lot of money
from Chinese indechoured laborers who worked
in such terrible conditions that it became
known in South Africa as quote ‘chinese
slavery’.
Another Southern African Imperialist and Oxford
benefactor was Alfred Beit, aforementioned
business partner of Rhodes. Beit endowed the
first professorship and lectureship in colonial
history at Oxford. The first historian to
take up this post was Hugh Egerton who once
stated that ‘Every school building [at Oxford]
is a citadel of Empire and every teacher its
sentinel.’ He also said that ‘It is equally
false to suggest that our empire took its
rise in violence. What happened was peaceful
occupation of, apparently, vacant lands’.
All of this, however, does not mean that everyone
at the University of Oxford was an imperialist
or a racist. Cornelia Sorabji, the first Indian
woman to come to study at Oxford, and also
the first woman at Oxford to study law, talked
about how even though she had to fight some
prejudice and racism at Oxford, there were
also people at Oxford that helped her fight
against that prejudice and racism. For example,
when she obtained the highest marks of her
class from Mumbai University, which ought
to qualify her for a scholarship at Oxford,
she was denied this spot because not only
was she an Indian, but she was also a woman.
However, hearing of this, Lord Hobhouse, an
Oxford graduate, helped her secure a different
scholarship at Oxford (at Somerville College).
Then, while at Oxford, she was initially denied
the opportunity to take the legal exams because
the examiners refused to test a woman, but,
when she told this to Benjamin Jowett, the
vice chancellor of the university, he made
sure that Sorabji could take the exam just
like any other student. Sorabji would later
write that she would never forget the ‘kindness
of everyone’ at Oxford who helped her and
that she ‘loved’ her time at the University.
This dichotomy of experiences, Sorabji and
many other colonial ‘non-white’ students
like Grantley Adams or Norman Manley faced,
was a common theme at the University. On the
one hand, there were students and faculty
members that treated them as friends and tried
helping them and, on the other, the University’s
system often worked against them and some
students and faculty members were outright
antagonistic and racist to them.
This was especially true if you tried to go
against the established white man’s burden
narrative, like in the case of Eric Williams,
who later became the first prime minister
of Trinidad and Tobago. Williams studied history
at Oxford and for his doctorate thesis in
1938 he wrote about The Economic Aspects of
the Abolition of the Slave Trade and West
Indian Slavery. In the writing of his thesis
he was helped by his advisor and by some of
the university’s fellows, but over all,
his questioning of the idea that slavery was
abolished due to economic reasons and not
moral ones was extremely controversial because
it went against the white man’s burden narrative.
Today the scale of the economic argument for
the abolishment of slavery is still being
debated, but no current historians are arguing
there was no economic influence, which is
something that most Williams’ contemporaries
didn’t even want to entertain let alone
debate. Williams’ thesis was so controversial,
in fact, that every British publisher, including
the press of the university where he wrote
the doctoral thesis at, refused to publish
his work. This was still during the time when
the University press was publishing the aforementioned
History of England book.
(long cut)
As the British Empire ‘formerly’ fell
apart in the latter half of the 20th century,
Oxford’s active connection to the Empire
also fell apart and the University, under
the rather accurate accusations of only producing
‘an anti-technological, arts-trained Oxbridge
dilettante elite’, had to undergo restructuring.
As the university could no longer count on
drawing its student body from the Empire’s
elite and sending it back to govern the Empire,
it began to shift its priorities. First, the
university became more global and started
to draw students, and also faculty members,
from all over the world, not just from the
anglophone sphere. And, second, the university
started to focus more on being a research
institution with frequent academic publications,
all while trying to become more inclusive
through various Oxford outreach initiatives.
The British Empire of the 19th and 20th century
is gone, and the University's connection to
it is part of history now. However, certain
Imperial legacies do remain, such as the statue
of Codrington in the All Souls Library, or
the statue of Rhodes at Oriel College, or
the name of the Rhodes’ Scholarship, or
the name of the Beit’s Professorship, etc.
These names and statues act as symbols of
the University’s Imperial past, a past that
means different things to different people.
To some, it symbolizes the greatness of the
British Empire while to others it symbolizes
the violence and racism the Empire inflicted,
the legacy of which can still be felt to this
day. It is the latter reason why movements
like ‘Rhodes Must Fall’ have organized
protests against Rhodes’ legacy at the University
of Oxford.
Why some people might feel particularly angry
about Rhodes can perhaps be best summarized
by Trevor Noah who, in his book Born a Crime,
stated ‘There is also this to consider:
The name Hitler does not offend a black South
African because Hitler is not the worst thing
a black South African can imagine. Every country
thinks their history is the most important,
and that's especially true in the West. But
if black South Africans could go back in time
and kill one person, Cecil Rhodes would come
up before Hitler.’ Rhodes is not Hitler,
but, just like Hitler, Rhodes does have a
legacy of violence, racism, and warmongering,
especially in Southern Africa.
Which begs the question, why do some people
at Oxford, and in Britain at large, want to
defend his statue?
Well, as Caroline Elkins states, ‘Questions
over whether “Rhodes Must Fall” are, of
course, proxies for much larger battles over
how we in the present remember the past.’
That is, the imperial legacy that is remembered
by some English people is not one of violence,
racism, and slavery but one of building projects,
scientific breakthroughs, and christianizing
missions.
When some English people look at Rhodes’
Imperial legacy at Oxford they don’t see
his violent actions in Africa as much as they
see the Grade 2 listed building he helped
fund, they don’t see his slave like compound
system, as much as they see his scholarship
helping fund students like Howard Florey;
who won the nobel prize for his work on penicillin,
arguably one of the most important medical
discoveries of the 20th century. The changing
or taking down of symbols that, to some English
people, represent this positive memory is
seen as erasing the ‘positive’ historical
aspects of the British Empire.
However, no one is talking about destroying
the Grade 2 listed building, no one is talking
about defunding the Rhode’s Scholarship,
no one is saying that nothing good came from
the British Empire, and no one is saying that
parts of the University, Condrington, and
other Imperialists aren’t products of their
time. Even the University press, which I mostly
talked about in a negative light in this video,
has many positive aspects and published this
book, Oxford and Empire, without which this
video would be impossible to make.
What people who protest against imperial symbols
actually want is the recognition that some
of these imperial symbols are products of
an unsavory past, and, therefore, should be
changed or taken down for they are quite anachronistic
in a modern society that views exploitation,
racism, slavery, and violence as things that
should not be praised.
As historian Richard J Evans said ‘statues,
monuments and memorials … are there to remind
us of who we are, or better put, who we want
to be as a nation. It is an obvious point
that some memorials are no longer fit for
purpose.’ Yes, statues, monuments, and memorials
symbolize the values of the society that put
them up but they also symbolize the values
of the society that chooses to keep them up;
and if your values make you defend a statue
of a man who once stated ‘kill all you can’
or ‘you must govern the natives … as a
subject race’, then perhaps it is time to
rethink your values.
...
Agh, this is the second time I am here. Second
time I woke up at 4:30 am. Because last time
I forgot to plug in the microphone.
It's good because there's no one here. Usually
during the day there's like a billion people
around.
The problematic nature is that I have to wake
up early, and even the more problematic nature
is that I have to do it twice.
But, haha, hopefully the video is good.
I hope you all enjoyed this video, I understand
this can be a quite contentious topic especially
in Britain, but I will conclude with this
quote from Sorabji which I found quite nice
when researching; she wrote ‘Best of all,
[at Oxford] I learnt that difference of opinion
need not affect friendship or personal appreciation.’
So next time when you’re talking to people
about this topic or are even typing something
in the comment section right now, please remember,
there is no reason why we all can’t be civil
when discussing the uncomfortable legacy of
the British empire.
or ... the uncomfortable parts of the British
Empire.